Welcome to the Gridiron Heights
Thanksgiving Day parade!
Great to be here, Al
First up, Philadelphia Eagles riding an easy
schedule to first place
And here come the Rams of Los Angeles!
Aw, look at their one fan, what a cute kid
Pretty sure that's their coach, Tony
and here's the Bills, off to a promising start!
(Cough) OK, Al, I've seen this before
You'll notice by the Buffalo's expression
the Bills are gonna get shaky, start going
up and down and then fully implode
Romo, you called it again!
Welcome back, the Patriots are cleaning
up the AFC East again
And here's the Titans with Marcus Mariota and
Ugh, Eric Decker maybe...
Oh wow, Eric Decker is on the Titans
And there's Philip Rivers
I don't think he knows he's in a parade, Al
Motherfreaking L.A. traffic goshdarnit!
And here comes the Packers float
But were just gonna show you Aaron Rodgers
watching the Packers' float
Sad, but still interested in his teammates
Great form
Oh no, Tony, the balloon hit its head!
It's heading in for evaluation
Oh good, he's cleared. I mean you gotta
let the balloons play
And here comes the 49ers in a celebration
of their one win!